hey guys so quick shout out to our
sponsor
third love the best bra you'll ever wear
and i'm currently wearing mine as always
because now i actually i
i switch out all my old bras and now i
only have third love bras because
they're amazing
and if you're interested check out the
fitting room quiz where you'll answer a
few questions and they will find
the very perfect bra for you and if you
don't love it every customer gets 60
days
to return returns and exchanges are free
and easy
third love knows your one true fit is
out there so right now they are offering
our listeners
20 off your first order go to
thirdlove.com
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 20
off your first purchase that's
thirdlove.com
big mood for 20 off today
hello welcome back to murder mystery
moon sexy boy yeah you're getting sexy
voices too i don't know why i mean
murder is true i'm sexy no no it's not
it's not
we're talking it's it's like this it's
like
all right well we made some drinks and
so that's maybe what's making me feel
sexy
so i try to keep the drinks simple for
you guys just three
ingredients we're making pina coladas
today no blender necessary a lot of
people think that they have to blend
their pina coladas you don't have to
it does make it nice and smooth but it's
very optional it still tastes good
so you're gonna want um four ounces of
rum i used malibu rum here four ounces
of
cream of coconut this is different than
coconut milk this is cream of coconut
cocoa lopez makes a really good one
not sponsored and then you're going to
want three ounces of pineapple juice and
you're just going to shake it up in a
shaker over ice get it nice and chilled
do it for like 15 seconds really get
that arm workout in
and then strain it over a fresh new cup
of ice
so it looks like this and then you're
gonna garnish with the cherry or
pineapple
up to you or whatever you want i mean no
judgment i just think the cherry looks
cute so
a hot dog all right okay
moving on stir it with a hot dog no
accept a hot dog do not garnish with the
hot dogs make a bloody mary
make a bloody mary and then you can why
are you judging nikki
okay i do i do judge i take it back you
live in hypocrite town nikki that's true
um today we are discussing the murder
mystery of
jonbenet ramsey
from my childhood everybody right she
would be our age right now she's
actually
she would be turning 31 this year so
she's going
to be our age you're putting yourself in
that there is yeah
i'm like [ __ ] we're old a couple years
older whatever
yeah i remember her from my childhood
for sure she was just plastered
everywhere because the thing about this
case and why it became so sensational is
because or sensationalized
is because she was this pageant star
at like she started her pageants at four
years old so she was six years old when
she was
murdered um but she had been winning
lots of pageants
for two years she was very composed and
so all this footage started coming out
of her and these pageants and it just
captured the heart of america
and they were like oh my gosh this girl
died horrifically and she was such a
beautiful young star um
it was it was in the 90s but it's
actually it was just past the 25th
anniversary
of when she was murdered and this case
is still not solved
and this is one of these cases the
reason why i chose this one even though
it's a big case
i try to go for not super big cases that
have been heavily covered but
this one is so crazy because it's one of
those
where the deeper that you dig the less
you know like you think you know
and then the more you dig the more you
find out that might not be the case and
it could be this thing and
it's really really hard and so exactly
so it really stuck with me and i'm gonna
try there's so much information like you
could really spend
months digging into all the details of
this case i'm gonna try to include as
much as possible but i know i'm gonna
leave
quite a few things out because there's
just no way to put it into an hour but
i'm gonna try to
do as much as possible and i'm gonna try
to pick this one because like i
do remember seeing like hearing her name
a lot as a kid but i just
didn't really fully grasp the entire
story yeah and then there were certain
like conspiracy theories that she she
wasn't really killed
or something and that oh like oh well i
mean we shot her body right so that's
kind of just ridiculous
right but then like you know theories of
like oh that was someone else
who knows i don't i don't know this
whole story so i'm really eager to hear
the whole
the whole thing yeah well good strap in
um
okay so i'm going to start with what we
know because there are so many theories
there are books documentaries tons of
them and depending on which one you
watch or read the person telling it has
their own theory and it's usually a
completely different theory than the
other than the next one
so here's what we know for sure this is
like all
facts okay and then i'll get to the
suspects and why they're suspects
so we're in boulder colorado we got a
family of four
and by the way boulder colorado is like
this
this like bubble like it's like rich
um like a fairytale land it's like trees
and snow
it's like beautiful snow bunny it's just
like this little like
resort area almost there's i think
there's a college there too but like
there's
like it's just really nice it's very
touristy it doesn't feel
unsafe at all it's just very beautiful
okay we got a family of four
we got patsy ramsay who's the mother we
got john ramsey who's the father
we got burke their son and jonbenet uh
the daughter
burke is nine jonbenet is six okay after
attending a christmas party on christmas
day so it's christmas
they go open presents they go to a
family friend's house they have a little
get-together a party
the ramsays go home and then jonbenet
and burke go to bed
the morning of december 26th 1996
patsy ramsey the mom discovers a ransom
note
on the back staircase of their home
their their home is like six thousand
square feet so they got a back staircase
okay yeah it's over six thousand square
feet so the ransom note states that
their six-year-old daughter jonbenet
ramsay has been kidnapped and they will
give her back in exchange for money
for a hundred eighteen thousand dollars
to be exact oddly specifically
yeah yeah 118 000 yes
someone from 10 years ago was like man i
needed a hundred thousand and then plus
like the cost of living increase i need
a hundred
two thousand it wasn't even that really
gotta pay this person back
but we'll get to that weird number soon
okay so there's a lot of weirdness with
this ransom note uh but uh yeah i'm
gonna we're gonna dissect all of it so
was it cut out like letters of
no but it's weird okay so
she finds a ransom note patsy immediate
oh by the way it says
not to call the police or they'll kill
the daughter patsy calls the police
right away like 9-1-1
immediately it's okay it's 5 52 a.m
she called their bluff wow didn't even
think about it police no she's in
hysterics she's calling the police
um to report her daughter is missing the
the police
royally botched this investigation just
like from the frickin
jump okay so they go over there and it's
like there's people already there like
from the ramsey's friends and family
they're people streaming through the
whole house so the whole like
scene is getting contaminated um they're
in every room they're passing the note
around
oh my god like just everything is
getting contaminated and the
investigators don't really say anything
because they they say at that time they
had no reason to suspect
that um the crime scene was the house so
they were like whatever about it but i
mean if she got kidnapped from the house
yeah
like it was an off day for the police
station they say uh like now they're
having a bad day in hindsight
it was after christmas they were all
drunk and hungover yeah exactly it's
their b team
maybe they don't really have a lot of
crime there so they're just not true
very qualified
like murder the investigator that got
left that day she hadn't dealt with any
homicide cases or kidnapping cases at
all she was pretty new
okay but so they bought you from the
beginning um they even some of their
friends are helping patsy wipe down the
kitchen
like they're destroying this crime scene
okay no way all the police leave because
they
they want to go find jonbenet it's a
kidnapping case so all the police leave
except for one officer linda arden i
don't know how to say her last name
aren't in the ransom note
it says the kidnapper will call between
five
between eight and ten so eight am and
ten am
they're going to call well eight am and
ten am passes and they never called the
ramseys didn't even seem too concerned
with meeting their demands by the
deadline like they just were
waiting for this call didn't happen
they're like
i guess it didn't happen so then um the
officer that's there is like why don't
we just take one more look around the
house just to like make sure
we've really found every searched every
credit
six thousand square feet so yeah yeah
maybe there's a place that people didn't
go
supposedly and this is according to
police officer john
the dad bee lines to the basement where
there's a spare room
finds the daughter immediately jonbenet
ramsay she
her body is deceased and it's
wrapped in a white blanket there's duct
tape over her mouth
and her hands are bound above her like
this
and he takes the blanket
with the body and brings her up the
stairs he was also told not to touch
anything if he finds anything
but he brings his daughter up the stairs
and lays her
on the floor of the living room where
everybody was walking
and then puts a new blanket on top of
her further contaminating the scene
um and that's when they they were like
okay she's in fact confirmed dead um
the autopsy found that jonbenet was
bludgeoned to death so she had a
uh like a crack in her skull but then
the coroner said it was death by
strangulation
because she also had what's called a
garat um
a garage yeah a garrote around her neck
which is a way of
string strangling somebody um this
particular one was with a wire
and then one of patsy's paint brushes
was used to
tighten it behind her neck
please yeah um that's super weird
right why both that's a weird yeah there
was dna found on
jonbenet's long johns and on her
underwear belonging to
a single unidentified man and they
searched this dna
among 1.5 million samples and could not
find a match
samples from like known pedophiles and
molesters
and her own family and her family yeah
and her own family
they could not find a match uh they did
find two sets of unidentified footprints
at the scene and a rope that did not
belong to the ramses was found by
jonbenet's room
there were no footprints on the snow
outside the house and no sign of forced
entry
well we can't even trust all that
because they contaminated the whole
[ __ ] crime scene
yeah that's true but in the towards
going towards the basement or away from
the basement where she was found where
the actual body was
yeah there were no footprints that were
going in and out no broken windows or
doors
no like unknown footprints because it
was the dad yeah there were unknown
footprints
in the house so one footprint uh
belonged to oh so there were two sets of
unknown footprints and they
had shoes that didn't match any of the
shoes that the ramseys owned
the police officers said they did search
that area but the room
was kind of like connected to the
basement and
they didn't know it was like a whole
room they just thought it was a closet
they were looking for
points of entry from the outside and
once they realized the door
swung the wrong way they were like oh
that can't possibly be
a door for the outside so they just
didn't even look in there wow these are
the worst cops ever i know
they really [ __ ] up the the first
initial
touchdown of the scene okay
let's get to the note though cause the
note is so [ __ ] s
weird and shady and bizarre like the
note is what won't get out of people's
minds
love definitely not the dad
okay first of all it's so long
it's two and a half pages a ransom note
it's two and a half pages like so most
ransom notes just for comparison if
you're not used to seeing a ransom no
they're really straight unto the point
so it's just like we have your kid she's
safe
it'll cost you five hundred thousand
dollars to get her back don't call the
police we'll be contacting you yeah but
done usually some sentences right this
one's like a manifesto or something i
know this is like two and a half pages
listen i need
ransom because my mom is in the hospital
broke her leg and but she also found out
that she has diabetes so i really need
money for i'm going to read it right now
you have two and a half pages well two
and a half pages on a notepad so it's
not that long
like a written out but okay so here's
how it goes
mr ramsay listen carefully we are a
group of individuals that represent a
small foreign faction
we crossed out respect your business
but business is misspelled but not the
country that it serves
at this time we have your daughter in
our possession possessions also
misspelled
she is safe and unharmed and if you
wanted her to see 1997 you must follow
our instructions to the letter
you will withdraw 118 000 from your
account
100 000 will be in 100 bills and the
remaining 18 020
bills make sure that you bring an
adequate size attache to the bank
attache
also had an accent mark in the proper
place so they
couldn't spell the other words were
misspelled but like oh because they're
foreign
a bag like that's all i'm calling it
yeah
from now on so bring an adequate size
bag to the bank when you get home you'll
put the money in a brown paper bag i
will call you between 8 and 10 am
tomorrow to instruct you on delivery
the delivery will be exhausting so i
advise you to be rested if we monitor
you getting the money early even advice
so get a lot of sleep okay yeah make
sure you eat lunch too
if we want to if we monitor you getting
the money early we might call you early
to arrange an earlier delivery of the
money and hence an earlier
delivery and then has crossed out and
says pick up of your daughter
any deviation of my instructions will
result in the immediate execution of
your daughter
you will also be denied her remains for
proper burial
the two gentlemen watching over your
daughter do not particularly like you so
i advise you not to provoke them
speaking to anyone about your situation
such as police fbi etc will
result in your daughter being beheaded
if we catch you talking to a stray dog
she dies
if you alert the bank authority she dies
if the money is in any way marked or
tampered with
she dies you will be able to tell me we
will be
scanned for electronic devices and if
any are found she dies
you can try to deceive us but be warned
that we are familiar with law
enforcement countermeasures and tactics
you stand a 99 chance of killing your
daughter if you try to outsmart us
follow our instructions and you stand a
100 chance of getting her back
you and your family are under constant
scrutiny as well as the authorities
don't try and grow a brain john
you are not the only fat cat around so
don't think that killing will be
difficult
don't underestimate us john use that
good southern common sense of yours
it's up to you now john victory sbtc
we don't know what the initial it's so
weird it's super weird because she was
just in the [ __ ] basement the whole
time
yeah so she was in the basement the
whole time it was also like there's a
couple weird pieces so one the 118
thousand dollars we talked about earlier
being a weird amount
it was also the exact amount that john
got a bonus for for christmas from his
company
so how many people know that right um
they also say
that we respect your business but not
the country that it serves as this
as if this is like an international
affair they also call themselves
a small foreign faction so they're
trying to like make themselves sound
big and almighty but then they call
themselves small which really
contradicts their power
and it's almost like someone's saying
like oh we're
powerful but you probably don't know us
you know
they wouldn't call themselves foreign
yeah like they would just say what
country they're from or whatever but
they wouldn't say
foreign because they're only foreign if
they're not from america
it's only four into america yeah it's
really really
dumb um it's also it's also been
discovered that some a lot of the
verbiage in here was
were lines directly taken from movies
yeah so the whole
is going to do this she dies she dies so
the movie ransom was actually playing in
the theaters at that
time in boulder colorado and a lot of
the
the lines from the bottom where it's
like you're not the only
fat cat or in town that sounds fake like
a
movie yeah dirty hairy and this movie
called ransom and a couple other movies
especially the don't try to grow brain
john so it's just someone like
trying to make what a ransom note might
sound like
in their brain from like watching it but
they overdid it
by like a lot yeah like they were just
trying to detail you could have just
wrote two sentences
we need money or your daughter dies
that's like a typical liar like you know
when you ask them like hey so
what is this thing that i found oh well
you know it's just because like when i
was coming back from
from work and then like i just ended up
bumping into like that one lady that
you know the lady i told told you about
all the time they think that the details
makes it sound more realistic because it
just like sounds like more of a liar
you're telling way too many details for
such a small story
it's just too much so also the fbi says
that they have
never had one kidnapping case in history
where the ransom note was 2.5 pages long
and had never had a case where the body
was then found in the house
and on top of this the ransom note was
written
at the crime scene with using a pen and
pad from inside the house
so they wrote whoever the kidnapper was
wrote the whole ransom note
from inside the house using their stuff
and then put the pen and paper back and
then just killed her anyway and put her
in the basement
yeah even normal people steal the pen
after yeah
you just don't even think you just put
in your pocket yeah unless it was habit
for you to put it back
right cause you live there interesting
um
a practice note was also found rough
so the first part of a no yeah okay
um wait they practiced and still messed
up so bad
yeah it looked like can we just spend
this video bullying the people who wrote
the note like you guys are [ __ ] dumb
well that's what the news did
so i don't even remember the part about
the note
yeah i guess i was like i was like 10 or
something honestly the more you dig into
this case
the note is the one thing like really
holding it up like
that makes it seem like it was somebody
in the ramsay family
but uh there was no dna left on the
clothing and if you want dna free
clothing
oh boy your sponsor stitch fix is gonna
love that transition good board
online shopping can be daunting you
never know things will fit returns are
difficult and you don't even know what
store to start with well that's me i
don't know where to shop i i barely like
any brand for all of its line i never
know where to go i'm like i like one
piece from here one piece from there but
i don't know what to do
it's too much for me to deal with and a
waste of my time i would rather someone
else
shop for me and i just say if i like it
or not and send it back if i don't
this season you can let stitch fix do
all the hard work
they offer clothing hand selected by
expert stylists for your unique size
style and budget
it's a completely different and fun way
to find clothes you will love to wear
you basically just go on take a little
quiz what kind of clothes you like you
pick the pictures of yeah i like that
style i'll try those clothes
or absolutely don't send me that and
then they won't
so the stylist will take your notes you
could try on
the pieces at home before you buy them
keep what you love and return what you
don't
they have a prepaid return envelope
included and there's no subscription
required you don't have to shop every
month you can just shop when you want
you could try it once or set up the
automatic deliveries you'll pay
just a twenty dollar styling fee for
each box which gets credited towards the
pieces you keep
and there are no hidden fees ever stitch
fix also has styles
and clothing to fit any occasion for men
women and kids
they ship all over the u.s and it's also
available in the uk
so get started today at stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mood for 25 off
when you keep
everything in your fix stitchfix.com
and if you're wearing brand new clothes
and you're looking great
you want to make sure that you're
wearing some nice comfortable underwear
right
that's where third love comes in third
love
they make these amazing bras i'm
actually wearing right now there you go
little peek right there
and uh honestly all my bras are now
third love
i got rid of all my other bras because
they were not comfortable i would always
have
issues with like the sizing especially
the cups or even the band
like sometimes when the band fits you
too tight you end up getting that like
side fat coming out and it's just it's
not attractive
it actually digs in not cute also the
straps
you know like no matter how much i would
try to adjust the straps
for some reason i always had issues with
my previous bras but not with third love
because before getting my bra
i took their fit finder quiz but now
third love just launched their fitting
room
and so it's a new and improved version
of the quiz
that focuses on size breast shape
current fit issues and your personal
style to deliver
bras and underwear that are perfect for
you
fit stylists are available for
one-on-one chats to answer
any questions as well and if you don't
love it every customer has 60 days to
return and returns and exchanges
are free and super easy just put it back
in the box that they shipped you your
stuff in and then you throw it in the
post office and you're good to go
so break up with your bad bra and fall
in love with better bras and underwear
from classic lace that actually feels
soft to their number one rated 24 7
classic t-shirt bra
check out all their exclusives at
thirdlove.com
third love knows your one true fit is
out there so right now they're offering
our listeners
20 off your first order go to
thirdlove.com
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra
and get twenty percent off your first
purchase that's thirdlove.com
big mood for 20 off today
hooray all right so back to this [ __ ]
up ransom note
okay i just finished that whole entire
drink and i can write a better ransom
note right now right
right they're way too strong oh by the
way
um the pina colada so pineapples
were uh jonbenet ramsay's favorite fruit
so tribute to her r.i.p baby girl we
little yeah
um so this note uh people have commented
that
parts parts of it kind of sound maternal
like the part
maternal yeah like about getting enough
rest i advise you to get enough rest
like it's hard for people to imagine a
man writing to get enough rest or and
like it sounds a little bit
like a housewife to some people so where
they're like
make sure you get enough rest make sure
you bring a big enough bag like most
ransom note levers maybe wouldn't be
concerned about what bag size
or how much rest you got and also about
like whether or not you get the
remains back for a burial you know so
people were kind of like it seems
a little bit maternal but you know
that's like
opinion and it's also really dumb yeah
it's uh quoted from movies and stuff uh
they did take handwriting samples from
the whole family burke and john's
handwriting was
ruled out completely but patsy's came
back inconclusive
oh really some some parts of the note
could be a match she dots her eyes with
a heart yeah no
i was actually watching a handwriting
sample person
or a handwriting analysis person um
go over what parts were similar and what
parts were and they were like
you know the way sh the way the a's were
drawn here and the way
patsy draws her a's where you lift the
pen at this part and blah blah blah
yeah but a lot of people do that so it's
not like
it could be her or it could not be her
like it's equal chances
could be her could couldn't be her yeah
and there was no way it was the dad
yeah no way it was a dad no way it was
the sun dad knew where the body was but
it was
it was a parent maybe maybe
maybe maybe she was jealous of how
beautiful her daughter was
so she also um patsy was
also a state a state champion debater
she graduated magna [ __ ] laude she
couldn't have written that stupid that
smelled like a degree
but it seemed like in the note they were
trying to purposely misspell some words
there was also wobbly letters like
someone was trying to kind of disguise
their handwriting
in it like it wasn't consistent with the
rest of the way they did the
handwriting um she graduated with a
degree in journalism and a minor
and a minor in advertising she was well
educated intelligent and a good writer
there were editors marks used at in at
least one spot and patsy would have been
familiar with these marks
wait what are editor's marks they're
like i don't i actually don't even know
like
i think the attache like the accents
maybe
um over certain words but i
it just says editor's marks yeah i
did not graduate magna [ __ ] laude with
journalism
um but patsy would know what that meant
and then the writer of the note had a
large vocabulary even though they tried
to disguise it with misspellings they
betrayed themselves with the correct use
and spelling of advanced words
so this drew a lot of people towards
thinking that maybe
it was an inside job like maybe the
parents did it either by accident
or maybe on purpose but maybe by
accident okay
so there was a lot of attention towards
patsy and john ramsey
specifically patsy because of this
possible match for the handwriting
and then that maybe john was like
helping her because
like he knew where the putty was right
away and there was no
signs of forced entry
other than that they also had an army of
lawyers that was preventing the police
from doing a proper investigation
so it took them the police like it took
them forever to like be able to
interview
the ramses because they had like friends
and lawyers being like give them space
to grieve
like how dare you they just got like
their child they just found their child
murdered in their home like they are not
doing well
give them space um and then the family
immediately within the days following
flew to atlanta georgia
to have dominic ramsey's body buried
there because that was i guess their
hometown
and john had a another daughter that
died in a car accident
okay yeah that was buried there how old
was she
i don't know how old she was but she was
one of his it was before patsy is before
in his previous marriage yeah um
so she got buried there and they were
like the police were like okay
let them bury their daughter they'll
come back we'll interview them but
instead
the ramsays then go meet with cnn in
atlanta
and do a national tv interview
um before talking the police so in this
interview
they're like the killer's still out
there like help us
they're like crying they're giving all
these things so police thought it was
kind of weird that
they couldn't speak to the police they
couldn't even get out of bed
but they went to atlanta and gave an
interview with cnn
nothing looks good on this family at all
right so there's a lot of things that
just don't
look good it's not a good look whether
or not they're guilty that's completely
that's a different topic but it just
doesn't look i mean they rushed to call
the cops even though the
note said not to but then now they won't
speak and then they weren't even trying
to get money together
or anything okay they also were hiding
medical records they were hiding phone
records
and then when they were released
apparently there was no activity at all
in december
so that was very odd um they
the police didn't get to separate the
separate them and interview them until a
year and a half later
yeah yeah a year and a half
i don't know like that was the first
time they actually got like a proper
interrogation separately
yeah because the lawyers just kept for
preventing things um
why would you not speak to the police
yeah exactly
seriously there were no footprints
outside the note was written from inside
the house
there was a theory that started
circulating that patsy
accidentally killed jonbenet over
bedwetting you probably heard this one
this was one of the earlier theories
because the nanny had said that she had
gotten really angry at jonbenet a few
times
for wetting the bed so there was a
theory circulating in the public that
maybe patsy you know accidentally killed
her over bed wedding and then they
staged the note and the strangulation
to make it look like someone broke in
you know wait the cause of death was the
strangulation or the blood
bludgeoning so there's debate on that
so apparently didn't you say the coroner
said it was a strangulation
yeah so it doesn't add up that it would
be an
accident and then cover it up with the
strangulation because apparently
according to the evidence jonbenet was
still alive during the strangulation oh
my god
yeah she was passed out from the
the bludgeoning but she was still alive
whoa okay other things that didn't add
up is that about the
it being the ramsays is that jambone had
markings on her neck
consistent with a stun gun and ram the
ramses don't own a stun gun
also the footprints that they found were
from high-tech
shoes the brand called high-tech and
they don't match any of those shoes
in the ramsey house well i mean they
would have just probably gotten rid of
the shoes right
maybe or also they were like people
walking throughout the house so i don't
know how they're even able to
say that these two sets of footprints
were from
i don't know i don't know how they were
able to rule that they could have thrown
away the sun gun too
so they never owned one yeah given to me
when they say like oh they never owned
that i'm like how do you know they
didn't have it
yeah right yeah you know at some point
yeah we're throwing giving it to a
friend to get
rid of yeah who knows in um
in 1999 a grand jury actually tried to
indict the ramses
owned child abuse cases on child abuse
leading to murder like
that would be the charge that they would
be getting charged for but the d.a said
that there wasn't enough evidence and
the grand jury had ultimately
decided to indict them because of the
lack of evidence of an intruder
and because of patsy's handwriting being
maybe a match but inevitably
dna cleared the whole family so their
the entire family got exonerated because
they didn't match the dna on
her underwear or the long johns right
who is this mystery dna what kind of dna
uh i didn't say it just said dna so not
that kind of dna although
some sources say there was evidence of
sexual abuse
using that the paint brush i mean what
dna was in the paper
yeah oh geez yeah
um and also some sources say there was a
droplet of blood
found but i don't know so
let's talk about some of the suspects
who are not the ramses just to
a lot of the news just focused heavily
on they only so they only suspected the
mom or the dad they didn't suspect the
brother not in the beginning
oh okay not really in the beginning um
but later
they did and so i'll get to that i think
that's the one i heard but yeah
yeah yeah as this case gets older and
older
and dna like dna
uh investigating gets a more what's it
called evolved um
like their the science gets better uh
they're able to reopen certain parts of
this case and so
new theories come out and new suspects
and that's why there's so many different
theories now because
there's just not enough evidence for any
of the suspects yeah
otherwise something would have happened
by now yeah exactly okay so here are
some of the suspects that
sound pretty legit this first one his
name is bill mcreynolds
he visited the family house a few days
before the murder so some people were
speculating that maybe the intruder had
been hiding in the house for
days to weeks you know because it's so
big yeah it's so big
for century mm-hmm uh maybe something
someone they knew
they came over for a house party and
stayed mm-hmm exactly
and maybe it was someone that jonbenet
trusted and so
she followed him down there who knows so
bill mcreynolds had visited the family
house a few days before the murder
sometimes he would come he would uh
dress up like santa during christmas
parties
he would hand out gifts his own daughter
was kidnapped
22 years before the murder jesus his
wife
wrote wrote a play about a child getting
molested and then murdered in a basement
oh my god
okay yeah wait when did she write that
one before after
before wow yeah uh but he said he felt
really close to her
and uh he says quote her murder was
harder than on me than my operation
she made a profound change in me end
quote she
actually uh jonbenet at one point had
given him a vial of glitter
uh as a gift during christmas and he
brought that vial of glitter with him
into
his heart surgery um he said that in all
his years playing santa claus and giving
out gifts that was the first time ever a
child had ever given him a gift back
so it meant a lot to him he brought in a
surgery and
he even told his wife that if he were
not to make it out of the surgery alive
to mix the glitter in with his ashes
that's so [ __ ] i want glitter ashes
that's a really good idea
yeah you guys think it's cute um the
medium i did not think it was i was
about to say i was like
was that crazy why makes glitter
of like some the neighbor girl you know
what yeah that is a little
too intimate i guess to be like oh this
is this little
smile is so important i guess if
if i just pictured him initially i just
pictured him like a grieving because you
said his daughter was usually
so it's like that hole of his
little girl yeah he had missing and now
it's like there's this
this little other little girl that like
is standing in for that and that
yeah that's like a broken-hearted
honestly
after thinking about this case for a
long time i do feel more that way i
think the media kind of
but they initially just made it sound
creepier without knowing that his
daughter died or like if if he didn't
have a child that died or a daughter
that died previously then yeah there's
no
way that would make any sense but being
a grieving father makes more sense
yeah also i feel really bad that like if
he was just that was a sweet thing and
then like
everyone made him creepy yeah i feel bad
some guys are just like big
teddy bear sweet sweethearts yeah and
like he could have been a creep
he could have been yeah but we don't
know those coincidences with the wife
writing that play on my pretty weird
yeah right maybe
the wife told them that the ramsay's
about the play and they decided to they
remembered it they're like oh let's
let's do that play thing
maybe there's also two sets of
footprints and they can put out that guy
yeah
okay the next oh ultimately he was not a
match for the dna
evidence okay so he was cleared the next
suspect we have his name is
gary oliva he lived a few blocks away
from the ramses
in december of 2000 he was arrested on
unrelated
drug charges and was carrying a photo of
jonbenet
he explained to the to the officers that
her death touched him very much
he felt a need to build a shrine to
remember her
okay creepy yeah and then in 2016
he was arrested for child pornography
okay there you go
yeah that guy's way creepier obviously
totally and
actually the more stuff comes out like
during this time period
they actually had 35 to 40 registered
sex offenders
are in their neighborhood like around
them and she's
performing she's this she's like the
little sexy
yeah and like if you see her which the
footage was everywhere
she was like it seemed like a little
adult you know like
full-blown makeup those pages are weird
they're very weird and so like
ultimately a lot of people
are kind of on the side of even if the
parents didn't kill her they
exposed her to all these creepy people
so
they kind of are mad at that like why
did you exploit your child and like
but patty patsy herself was a pageant
queen
yeah so she was kind of in that that's
kind of tough it's kind of tough because
like i mean i get the pageant thing and
i get that being something you want to
share with your child like your
daughter's gonna you know they've had
that's like a cultural thing
before social media yeah this was like
way way i think they realized she was
gonna be as famous as she was like
i mean you a lot of like little pageant
kids go around they just do some little
local pageants and then yeah they go off
to college and they're cheerleaders or
something but like
i don't think anyone expected her to be
you know so it's kind of weird to be
like oh you did this by
exposing her to the world but like she
just got famous like how does that
happen that doesn't happen to
you it was kind of the reason that she
got sensationalized too this was like as
close to going viral as you could get at
this time period
she was in every single magazine on
every in every grocery store i remember
just seeing her everywhere
um so this oliva guy this creep creep
guy um he got
you know charged with child pornography
what's even weirder
is that the day after jonbenet's murder
his high school friend named michael
vale says that the day after the murder
uh gary oliva called him and said i
heard a little girl i heard a little
girl
according to the friend i hurt i hurt a
little girl i hurt a little girl
he called who knows his friend from high
school wow
yeah gary oliva the creepo called his
friend from high school the day after
the murder and said i killed a little i
hurt a little girl i heard a little girl
according to the friend gary also
revealed the location of where he hurt
the girl
which was boulder colorado and according
to police records
no other little girl was harmed in
boulder colorado on that night
wow vail the friend also revealed that
the strangulation method that um was
used on jonbenet with the wire you know
the garrote
uh was also used by gary previously when
he attempted to strangle his own mother
with a telephone cord how is this not
enough evidence yeah
right what is that it seems like a lot
of evidence it's all like
circumstantial i guess and then did they
check if he owned
those pair of shoes in the dna
so the witness testimony means nothing
yeah
yeah i don't know uh well not witness
there was no witnesses
phone calls he said he he or he said he
called his friend like why would he make
that up
my friend called me and told me he did
it what's why did he make that up so he
was
well he was brought in but he was not a
match for the dna so they cleared him
so that's the only thing that they're
using
yeah to clear people literally only
whoever's dna
yeah could that dna not like because i
want to know what kind of dna it is
because
what could that have been just something
else like unrelated to the murder
well or is it like [ __ ] come like
okay we have more information okay
the dna that's what's that's what's
frustrating me yeah
um okay so before i get to the
next couple suspects because it gets it
gets juicier yes
um she was blonde right she was blonde
yeah to keep your hair
that blonde you got to have some good
shampoo because
it could get brittle especially if it's
a bleach transition i'm not proud of
that
no function of beauty is a great
great so oh my god i freaking love this
brand i do my hair has been forever
changed by this shampoo and
well actually they make way more than
shampoo and conditioner body wash
yeah i finally use the body wash and i'm
like oh my gosh why did i
prevent myself from having this pleasure
it's so good it smells so bomb it makes
my skin feel so good if you haven't
tried it yet like the hype is real
seriously believe the hype um you go
online you
complete a test right like all these
quizzes that these custom
these custom quizzes all these companies
do this one's so legit
so the quiz is like what's your hair
type like is it wavy is it straight
how thick is it they quiz you about your
hair then they quiz you about your hair
goals like do you want it shiny do you
want more volume what like what is it
you want
then they're able to there's there's
like three hundred thousand combinations
54 trillion possible formulations oh my
god
and then um function of beauty has over
fifty thousand five star reviews
but yeah so all those formulations they
make
the most custom formula for you and then
you even get to pick out the scent
you and the color i think mine that i'm
using right now is peach and i used yeah
peach with a peach scent but i've used
them all i've done the tea
i've done the eucalyptus i've done
the uh the rose yes it's my favorite
it's really good
okay and then um yeah so you it's a
subscription so you never have to buy
off the shelf
just to be disappointed ever again go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
off your first order
that applies to their full range of
customized hair skin and body products
go to functionalbeauty.com big mood to
let them know that we sent you and to
get 20
off your order functionalbeauty.com big
big mood imagine jumping into the shower
not turning on the water
just wiping your body with dry paper
yeah oh you crazy right
that's weird yeah so why are you wiping
your butt butt with just a dry
piece of toilet paper right all right
bring your mom into the future with the
brand new hello tishi 3.0 modern bidet
attachment it's
stylish eco-friendly easy to install and
will help stop flushing her retirement
down the toilet
in tp costs you don't need a plug or an
outlet
either yeah it cleans your butt like a
champ
but it doesn't stop there it also cleans
itself with the smart spray automatic
self-cleaning nozzle
when we say anyone can put this [ __ ]
together we mean even your parents
it's true my parents yeah you know
anyone your parents have to ask you to
remember their password
yes yeah well she can actually install a
hello tissue by herself
hello tissue 3.0 attaches to their
existing toilet with no electricity
extra plumbing or tech support face
times to you and cuts toilet paper use
by eighty percent
so that means the hell of tissue body
pays for itself in only a few months
plus every hello tissue by day
attachment comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty you know how asian parents love
that
so give the gift of a clean butt to your
mama go to hellotissue.com
big mood to get 10 off plus free
shipping
this is a special offer for our
listeners it's at hellotissue.com
big mood for ten percent off again
that's hellotissue.com
big mood is that because mother's day is
coming up yeah
yeah she deserves a bidet yeah yeah how
many times you actually like think about
your mom having a dirty butt you know so
now's the chance of cleaning it
plus the puns of the car like happy
mother's bidet
got him moving on the list of suspects
this next guy [ __ ] weirdo okay
this guy john mark carr do you remember
him at all
no okay there's a lot of john's in there
yeah there are yeah
and there's a lot of michaels who are
friends it's really weird okay
so john mark carr didn't become a
suspect until
10 years later in 2006 yeah
he confessed to the murder via email
to a journalism professor named michael
tracy and elder michael right
michael tracy who had been emailing with
this dude for four years to gain his
trust
so he's just emailing this weirdo
suspect for four years to try to get his
friend
yeah i don't even know like what they
talked about
um but yeah he talked about this
journalist is like really digging in for
this story
jesus like who lived within the [ __ ]
three-mile radius
well imagine that being the one that
breaks the case that i guess
at this point it's been 10 years they're
like this is like why is this person
still
thinking about it i don't know i want to
know how he even became a suspect for
this journalist at all
honestly i don't know other than the
fact that the the cops had
a list of suspects that they felt like
they narrowed it down
the one of the originals was yeah one of
the original statements by the boulder
uh police department was that we have
a list and your name is on it and it's
only a matter of time until the last
person on the list is you
like that was their like threat to
whoever was out there that did this
so this guy's this guy was on the list
um so
john mark carr ends up emailing this
journalist a confession
and he details a really gruesome
story of how he killed jonbenet he used
similar verbage to the ransom note and
even used patsy's mom's nickname
neddy which was like how did he even
know that oh [ __ ] we don't know
patsy's mom's nickname yeah huh
oh poor grandmother then so germany's
grandmother yeah okay
maybe she said his name wait the
grandmother's nickname for the nickname
just her nickname that's right yeah but
she only went by that
to the family so like how did he know
that he also confessed he was in love
with sean benay
he confessed to hitting germany in the
head with the flashlight
he said that he never meant to disgrace
her and
the saddest part that really hurts him
is that she was left there like he
didn't mean
for her to ever like stay in that room
that like he didn't mean to disgrace her
it was just unfortunate what happened it
was
kind of an accident okay about the
strangulation
yeah exactly you accidentally hit her
it's like oh well they didn't give me
the money
so i strangled her um how do you get out
with cops there
i don't we don't know so in 2008
two years after this confession with the
help of several government agencies they
were able to locate him in bangkok
thailand
where he was hiking into thailand he was
he was hiding from child pornography
charges of course
man why are there so many damn pedos
seriously so the dna didn't match
and some of his story didn't line up
either like it like it didn't
make sense at all with the evidence like
did he just want to go to jail
like do you think he has some sort of
ultimately other [ __ ]
no i think ultimately the cops said that
they thought he wanted notoriety and
fame oh so they just didn't
but he was like i'm just gonna be in in
bangkok you can't come get me or
something
yeah well that was to avoid the previous
child pornography charges
but this one was like he wanted to be
known
as the guy yeah illness
yeah um and then also the department of
homeland security continued to
investigate him because he always
maintained that he didn't act alone you
know
and there was two sets of footprints so
they were like well maybe we should keep
investigating him just in case he's
associated
but then it was later confirmed that he
wasn't even in colorado at that time oh
wow
so wasn't it bangkok the whole time i
don't it doesn't say where he was
but he wasn't in colorado damn yeah
okay so then oh there was also this
other guy
who i forgot to write down his name but
he was heavily suspicious too so he was
another
creepo that was in the neighborhood and
he had confessed to his friend
that he killed a girl right after the
murder um
and he had a stun gun
that matched like you know where the
dots lined up
and he had a pair of high-tech shoes one
of those that brand of shoes
um and apparently he got so scared
when the police department was saying we
know
you're going to be the last person on
this list that he committed suicide
whoa oh my god maybe it was him then it
could have been
like why else would you just straight up
commit suicide
maybe you're a little not all there oh i
suppose i mean it could have very well
been him but
either he did it or if he was crazy yeah
um okay so then
you were talking about the brother yeah
that's the one i heard hey
like why didn't they investigate him
okay so in a cbs documentary
that came out a few years ago i think it
was 2016. yeah that's what i recently
heard
yeah in 2016 there's a cbs documentary
and by the way before i get into this he
has been known to be very litigious
and he went after litigious
litigious is it lydicus no it's not
is it not it's litigious i only know
that it goes from clueless like
her dad's a litigator and okay
yeah okay look we live in a litigious
society yeah
yeah okay so anyway so he's been known
to go after people
legally um and after this documentary
came out he sued several people
that were associated with this
documentary
these are no personal opinions nor am i
saying any of this is evidence that is
real
um this is just what is was presented in
the documentary i'm just going to
tell you what was presented in this
documentary not my personal opinion okay
um so in this documentary they had
first of all they had a dna expert named
dr henry lee who is known from the o.j
simpson case who examined the dna and he
held this theory that the dna from
jonbenet's underwear may have possibly
come from a factory
that made the underwear and he proved
his theory by testing an unopened bag
from the same brand of underwear which
showed to also have
unknown male dna on them yeah what is
the dna
[ __ ] before you wear it she probably got
these the underwear whatever for
christmas and they just threw it on her
yeah the night before yeah wait so but
it was also on her
long john so how wet was it to transfer
to another piece of clothing
or what kind of dna was it it could have
been like the same brand
also it's the same guy just nutting on
all these [ __ ] new badges
chinese people just like they cough with
their mouth open
well there's touch dna now where you
just i touch this laptop
and my dna is on it now like skin cells
yeah not on clothing yeah that's true i
don't i don't know
all the forensics but i do know that the
science has gotten way better
um but anyway dna they've been canceling
all these suspects because it didn't
match the dna and they turn around and
say the dna is
so in this documentary because this
doctor did not testify in court or
anything else
in the documentary um but the
documentary concluded because of this
that this made the dna fallacious
and opens it up to all the previous
suspects right right so that was the
first thing because if you remember the
ramses were exonerated because their dna
didn't match the only reason they
stopped investigating they're like oh
thank god they found some other dna
yeah by the way they did look very very
sad that they lost their eye it wasn't
like
they were like faking it or anything
like that but we don't know what
happened like
why did the daughter die okay so burke
ramsay
starts getting kind of like like they
kind of
start digging down that rabbit hole in
this documentary and there were a few
things
uh that raised suspicions so
according to other stories of burke that
from people that knew him
such as the housekeeper the housekeeper
yeah there was a housekeeper there she
at one point was a suspect but then she
got rolled out somehow and i don't
and there wasn't enough evidence at all
to to try to
charge her with anything um but she kind
of was telling stories
of how the family acted and
burke apparently according to
people he had kind of a temper problem
you know he
was aggressive towards his sister a lot
like they would fight and he'd be really
aggressive
at one one time he hit her with a golf
club
damn so um
maybe because she was getting a lot of
attention as a beauty pageant
i mean also like kids they fight each
other like civilians fight
like they wrestle they fight like but
also him being a boy and him getting a
little bit older he might not realize
his strength
yeah and he was he just was overpowering
for sure
um he's only a couple years older than
her right like four years older
three three yeah yeah so
there's this pineapple theory where oh
no
yeah i heard this one this was in the
documentary so
what was weird is there was pineapple
the night that she got murdered there
was pineapple
left on the kitchen on the table um
pineapple with milk in it which was
burke's favorite fruit
burke loved pineapple with milk in it as
a snack what the hell
yeah and there was a bowl with burke's
fingerprints on it and
patsy's fingerprints on it and patsy
washed the dishes so maybe
it could have been her but um there was
definitely burke that was eating from
this bowl
and this bowl was in the pictures from
the crime scene
that they took so this is where they
found this
from and uh the
theory is that a lot of times you know
they would get into sibling fights and
he's very aggressive
a theory is that she might have tried to
like take some of his
pineapple like to have some because
there was pineapple found in her stomach
and maybe he didn't like that because
this was an area of the house where only
really burke went
anyway because he had a train set down
there so he had a
whole like model train set that went
around a track basement yeah
in the basement and in the spare room
that was adjacent to the basement
okay and so it would really only be
burke that would
know about or would be down there at all
um and the theory is that
jonbenet took someone's pineapple and
then they got into a fight about it
they went down to that room
and burke hit her over the head really
hard with part of his train track
um train train train set train set yeah
train track
yeah a piece of that set and the
markings
the markings on her head from that
fracture matched
pieces of the train set also thomas the
train
got it it's like an actual like look
realistic
yeah um also those markings that we
thought was a stun gun
um it also perfectly matched the train
track
uh the way that the pieces fit together
yeah so that mark kind of matched maybe
it wasn't a stun gun
right because this guy killed himself
for no reason also
the other reason um the knots like she's
bound it's like well who like bound her
burke was in boy scouts and had a book
full of knots like different
ways of tying knots and so um the other
theory is like okay so maybe he hit over
the head
got scared and he's a small boy so
um maybe he put it around her neck and
dragged her to the room
because she he couldn't lift her up
because any adult would kind of
would probably lift her into wherever
she ended up
but the marks on the wires were pulling
upwards
oh [ __ ] yeah she's getting dragged
that's usually how you would kill me
yeah like if it was around the back
up yeah it could be upwards but then
some people were speculating that maybe
it was like because he dragged her maybe
maybe
and she was still alive at this time but
maybe as a kid you don't know that your
sister's still alive or that
maybe you don't know i don't know or we
just don't know there's not enough
evidence for
what is happening so there's just like
speculation about this because this is a
new theory
this was like 20 years after the after
the fact like and no one had
investigated burke also when did the
investigation of these train tracks
happen though it can't be like
20 years later and they go back to the
train track so they did a whole
remodeling oh geez
the crime scene they rebuilt the
basement to the t you said pictures of
the brand of the train tracks and they
could do the measuring
yeah yeah and so they they re because
this case is like
it's like the jfk case where it just is
not solvable
people get obsessed because they just
want to solve it right which is good
because like
come on it's been 25 years so the these
people
reenacted the entire scene and that's
what they found was that like there's
pineapple in her stomach there was
pineapple found on the
on the kitchen table um there's
fingerprints from burke on the pineapple
like he's known to have this past
aggressive behavior with her
and then there's uh some videos of when
they interrogate him
after the after the murder and this is
like
the initial like when they took him away
to like just to have him
away from the crime scene and everything
and they had a
child i don't know interviewer or
therapist there
that was like meant to make the child
feel comfortable and also to kind of get
their version of what happened
and in this video he is not concerned or
doesn't seem to be concerned at all
about his sister
just getting brutally murdered he talks
about how he's having a lot of fun
playing video games and
and the interviewer says like how do you
so what do you know about how she died
how do you think she died
and he goes um well i think like uh
i think the kidnapper like took her like
tiptoed maybe so no one could hear
took her out of bed and took her down
and then maybe like
stabbed her with a knife i don't know or
like uh he's like just kind of like
enthusiastic about reenacting how he
thinks his sister might have died
and he's laughing the whole time and
he's um
it's just very odd behavior and then the
interviewer says so do you feel safe at
your house and he's like
yeah yeah like i feel really good that's
when he was a kid yes
and this was right after like nine so
your sister just gets brutally murdered
in your house right next to you
or like you know in the same house as
you and he feels perfectly fine
um the kid's reaction kids are different
yeah yeah like a coping mechanism
yeah the the argument about this is like
it could also be coping mechanisms or
trauma
he also talks about how how like
exciting it
is that the press wants to find him at a
school
and like that he everyone's asking where
burke is
and stuff like that and he's smiling the
whole time
um he also as an adult
went on dr phil's show and gave an
interview
and is smiling the whole time and so
people felt like it was really
creepy just an odd person yeah
and you can watch these videos and watch
that now yeah because
it's it's pretty it's pretty odd but um
also during the
when he was a kid uh the person asked
him to draw a picture of his family
and he drove his mom then he drew his
dad and you drew him
and then they were like is there anyone
else nope
didn't draw anybody else well maybe
because she's dead and that's how a kid
just like
she's not here anymore yeah that was
after she died yeah
that was right after after she died also
um
they were asking him what his favorite
fruit was and
um they showed him a picture of the
pineapple that was left on the table
and asked him what it was and he goes oh
that's something and he just won't say
he won't say what it is as an adult no
as a kid
as a kid still oh that's yeah yeah so
it's
it's interesting um and i
i guess you could see where the
documentary was going
but there's still not enough there's no
evidence
to really press any charges or make any
convictions
and we'll also like say if it was a
little kid
right like obviously he's not going to
be in jail because he's just like a
little 10 year old so that's like this
one's more about if the parents helped
them cover exactly
that's the real that's the real issue
and
there was a there was an interview with
the 9-1-1 operator
that took the call that day and she
says that what was really weird is at
the end of the call patsy
thought she hung up the phone but it
wasn't all the way hung up so she was in
hysterics she was like oh my god they
got my they have my daughter
all the stuff and then the phone was
like she thought it was hung up and then
she
goes okay so i called the police now
what and
um you can hear
what sounds like might be burke's voice
as a child in the background and then
the mom says what did you do
but it's not confirmed they had audio
experts analyze the end of this call
and they said that it's too muffled
muffled to really know for sure
what was said and who said it is the
audio available
yes yes you can hear the audio um
also they what was weird about that is
they had claimed that burke was still
sleeping
at this time so he shouldn't have been
on the 911 call and even if he
like even if he wasn't sleeping why did
they say he was like why did they have
to have that detail
in there um yeah they're clearly
protecting him which
it seems that way so that's what makes
the ramses continue to be
the center of what poo people think
probably did it
but we there's no like the evidence is
so
botched like the crime scene is so much
that it's almost like impossible to know
for sure
there was this one and this is the last
thing i was saying there's this one
investigator
his name's lou smith he is like this
badass [ __ ]
case-solving investigator he's just
known to be a bulldog and just solve
cases he just like crushes cases
he has solved over 200 cases he came out
of retirement for this case because it
just wasn't getting solved
right they like brought in the big dog
right and
inevitably he left the case because the
police would not
pursue the option of there being an
intruder and he feels with all his heart
that it was an intruder so even after he
left the case he continued to
investigate
because he really really feels it's an
intruder and
he he even his dying wish like people
were visiting him on his deathbed
and he would not stop talking about the
case even when he was on his deathbed
and his dying wish was that this case
does not die with him
he says he's like a hundred percent sure
it was an intruder
and so his family his two granddaughters
who are about the same age as jonbenet
um started a podcast called the victim's
shoes
and it's dedicated to this case because
they promised him they would not
stop searching for who the killer is and
stop
and they would never stop finding
evidence and investigating it
so they're um they're saying it's very
slow because it costs a lot of money
and all the stuff but they're never
gonna stop and they truly feel like
it was an intruder one of the reasons
people thought it wasn't an intruder
was that they thought the window was too
small for a person to fit through but
then
this guy loose schmidt just showed them
that he could fit through it like he
actually went through it
himself wonder what made him feel so
strongly about that because it didn't
seem like there was really any clear
evidence right
they said that he says that the police
were so
sure that it's someone in the ramsey
family that they won't even go pursue
um the thought of it being an intruder
so he just doesn't like
holes and yeah investigation methods and
he just feels like
the evidence is pointing to behavior
that is normally consistent
with um a murderer or
kidnapper yeah like from someone outside
the home
he also personally interrogated john
ramsey
and he felt like they acted their
behavior was normal for parents that
had gone through a kidnapping or a
murder
yeah so that's bizarre
he just like really is hardset that it's
it was an intruder
damn who do you guys think it was for
legal purposes we will not say
who we think is the killer well we have
high suspicion i'm pretty thrown off by
the interrogate or that investigator
like being a lifetime crime solving and
he doesn't think it was the family so
that
that kind of throws me off i'm like well
he seems to be the most
expert we have in this whole case
because all the other cops blundered the
whole thing so if he's the most expert
person on the case and he doesn't think
it was them then yeah
maybe it wasn't yeah so there's so much
room for doubt
in every direction that you go that it's
like because then i come back to the
ransom note like
that definitely looks staged yeah but i
don't know
like i don't know [ __ ] maybe maybe it
wasn't maybe it was a really stupid
criminal yeah just like
i mean i'm i can picture like a pedo
who's just kind of like an idiot like a
basement dweller type of dude
yeah like he's not very smart writes two
and a half pages yeah
so i don't know yeah we don't know oh
man it's gonna be one of those things
see now like you know they always ask
you questions like
when you die what do you want to ask god
and be like all right who did it
uh yeah right i just need to know now
that and jfk i'm like who yeah
you tell me there's so many there's so
many there's so many there's so many
unsolved things
i know but this one like really just
happened to atlantis
tell me was it real was it real well the
aliens still live there so yeah of
course it's real
but anyway tell us in the comments who
you think did it because you are not
under any sort of
uh litigious activity
but i think this is just a really
interesting case it's very bizarre
there's so many things that don't add up
it's almost like there's so much
information
and then also not enough information all
at the same time
and the deeper you dive the less you
know like you just
you just don't even know anymore it's
crazy so
it's crazy how many like uh what is it
pedo people are in that neighborhood
yeah like yeah it's a boulder or it's
just a sex offender list so maybe
they're not all pedos
yeah the sex offender list yeah yeah it
could have
it could be above age but so many child
pornography charges
yeah i mean these people probably went
to the pageants
come on yeah yikes yeah
anyway thanks for tuning in for murder
mystery mood we love these and we love
you and
if you have any requests leave them in
the comments and if you think you know
who done it leave it in the comments
we've done it
and we'll see you soon i love you make
these pina coladas though yeah they're
good they're so good